(hip hop music)
- [Rome] You know they
call me "Smash and Dash."
(door knocks)
(indistinguishable conversation)
- Hey.
- You look a lot different
in your profile picture.
Let me see....
Close enough.
Alright cool.
- Come in.
Alright.
You got some nice wood in here.
- Hi handsome, how
can I help you?
- We want to cash this
check actually, please.
- With pleasure.
Meaning it will be very
pleasurable for me.
Dorm enematainment.
Are you guys starving students?
Are you stripping to
pay tuition, because you
look like a stripper.
- No.
Not you.
You look like a mighty duck.
- Actually it's dormtainment
It's not that hard.
- As you were saying.
- Yeah, we do sketch comedy and
stuff like that.
- I love comedy!
Make me laugh?
- We really don't
do that type of....
(laughs)
- Oh my god, that's
so hilarious.
Now I just wish you'd
make my vagina laugh.
(laughs)
- Hey you guys.
How you guys doing?
Who wants to get robbed?
Okay, listen. Here's
what's gonna happen,
you fucking slut.
You're gonna do what
I say, or I'm gonna
blow Kid and Play's
brains out, okay?
- I'm just gonna show
Rome something upstairs,
but my roommate Carey
is dying to meet you.
Yo Carey!
The guy from the
internet video's here.
(R&B music)
(giggles)
- Hey.
I'm Carey.
- I don't care.
- You're a lot cuter in person.
- Shit, I'm cute
in unperson too.
- Do you want anything?
And I mean....anything.
- Listen, I don't know who told
you what. Or what you know.
But I have a girlfriend,
okay? So you can't do nothing
for me. And I mean nothing.
- Do you want a drink?
- Yeah, I'll take something
to drink. I'm kinda thirsty.
(both chuckle)
- So, what do you want to drink?
We have Fiji, Perrier, Gatorade.
- You got anything
that ain't French?
- Gatorade.
- I'll take Gatorade.
You know my dad used
to work for Gatorade.
He'd be having all the
new flavors and shit.
Thunderblast, Tornado
Wind, Ocean Salt, yeah.
- Interesting.
- You know I don't really like
telling people that though,
'cause then they only goin'
want me for my Gatorade connect.
You need a girl who goin'
want you for you....
- [Amanuel] Where's
the Starbucks?
Chaz come on man,
let's walk.
- I'm.... I need....
- Let's keep walking,
man. 'Cause....
- You know what?
Excuse me sir, do you know
where I could shit at?
- Chaz, we not doin' that man.
We have respect for....
- No. No, no, no....
- Don't do that Chaz.
Okay.
- Come on please.
Oh shit!
The Grim's comin' out my ass.
Oh God.
- Give me the money
you fuckin' slut.
- Just don't hurt him.
- Oh, don't hurt this
one? You like this one?
Give me the money,
you fuckin' slut!
Put it through the
slit slut. Now!
- Enough with the slut shaming.
Take the money.
- You know what they say bitch,
once you go black, we
don't want you back.
Alright, what else you guys got?
- I ain't got nothin'.
- What's this
shit, huh? A check?
Do I look like I
got a license, huh?
- You stupid peace of
shit, give me your watch!
- Hey man, my daddy
gave me this watch.
- Your daddy could
suck this fuckin' cock.
Just like you're gonna
suck both of these cocks.
(laughs) I'm out. Fuck you guys.
Kid and Play could suck a dick.
- Do you think I'm a slut?
I am.
- Ooh, that was fun.
- Uh uh, uh uh, you are not
trying to leave already.
- Listen,
Krist...Krist...Krista....
- Kristy!
- No, no, I got it, I got it.
I've been thinking, and
this isn't going to work out
between me and you.
- Just go.
- That's cool.
- Get out. (sighs)
(Carey pants and grunts)
- You like Gatorade?
- What the hell? Get
off of my friend.
He has a girlfriend.
But I don't.
- You just had sex
with my roommate.
- We just broke up.
- [Chaz] You know
what I'm sayin?
I'm hungry again, man.
- Do you ever stop eating, dog?
- No. Basically I got like
a Greek god of a body.
So Zeus came down like
"boop." There you go Chaz .
You know what I'm saying?
- Ain't that where
the car used to be at?
Like, I'm not trippin' right?
- Where's the car?
- [Amanuel] I thought y'all
was at the car.
- Y'all supposed
to stay by the car.
- Yeah, okay you
said that, but....
- Someone stole the car?
- Why you carrying Mike?
- He was sexually
assaulted by a woman.
(police sirens)
- Freeze BLACKstreet.
Make a move, I'll shoot you
right in your FUBU jeans.
Have you guys been robbing
check cashing places? Huh?
- No sir.
- You throw a gun in a
little white girl's face?
You got her all
scared and horny?
That little pervert
was freaking out.
You guys listen to some Lil'
Jon, get all cruncked up,
all fired up?
Start riding dirty?
Drinking that codeine shit?
- Officer, we had
nothing to do with that.
- Why'd I get a report
that you did that?
- That was the dick
sucking robber.
He was talking a lot about
sucking dick, I don't know.
- What's up with
the little guy, huh?
What are you smiling
at, little guy?
Turn down for what?
- I was helping my friend shit.
- He just held my butt
cheeks open while I was....
- Whoomp, there it isn't.
(mumbling on police radio)
- That's your problem,
Cam. You always playing.
Stop playing!
- If they didn't leave the car,
this would have never happened.
- They the ones
that left the car.
(arguing)
- Shut the fuck up, man.
- Hey, Poo Tang Clan,
(knocks) knock it off!
- Hey, who the fuck you
calling Poo Tang Clan?
(slow electronic beat)
(hip hop music)